wir bleiben bei der deutschen politik
und gehen zu armin laschet wer finden
nachts verfolgt weil ich habe wirklich
bis zuletzt leidenschaftlich verteidigt
und habe auch immer auch in so einem
schlechten moment noch das quäntchen
gute gesehen jetzt muss ich aber sagen
bin ich extrem verwundert armin laschet
hatte ein zukunftsteam aufgestellt unter
anderem soziale aber auch mit peter
neumann und jetzt plötzlich ist vom
zukunftsteam eigentlich nichts mehr über
also es geht jetzt die verhandlungen
denn vilja aufbruch zukunft schaffen
setzt aber wieder nur auf die alte garde
außerhalb von silvia breher die dabei
ist wie kann das sein ich frage mich war
das zukunftsteam nur verstehen sie mich
nicht falsch ich finde die idee ganz
toll fand sie damals toll dass jemand
kanzler werden will und sagt ich schaffe
ein team um mich rum aber es war
überhaupt nicht ernst gemeint war es
dann fast schon hart gesagt villa
verarsche also da muss ich dir
tatsächlich ein bisschen widersprechen
lena weil damals martin schulz hatte
auch ein zukunftsteam ist auch nicht
viel von übrig geblieben warum wir
müssen uns ja die frage stellen was soll
dann ein zukunftsziel machen neue ideen
innovationen reingeben auch irgendwo den
kandidaten in dem falle begleiten auch
mit ganz ganz frischem wind frischt im
blickwinkel und das sind aber nicht die
leute die nachher die wirklich harten
politischen sondierung führen müssen
also das sehe ich zum beispiel so dass
du wirklich da eine ganz andere
erfahrung in dieser trockenen politik
welt braucht und in zukunft ziehen kann
wiederkommen deswegen würde ich das
nicht ausschließen dass wir vielleicht
irgendwann diese köpfe auch wiedersehen
ich glaube den zentralen satz hatten
jedoch gesagt armin laschet hat da ein
zukunftsteam aufgestellt und der satz
stimmt ja eigentlich gar nicht armin
laschet wurde auf den allerletzten
metern gedrungen gefleht bekniet von
seiner partei auch irgendwas zu machen
was von ihm aber er vorgestellt hat das
aber aufgestellt hat das nicht er wurde
geradezu gezwungen das aufzustellen
damit ist noch irgendwas gibt sogar um
zu sagen was von ihm ablenkt kennen
damit die leute nicht einmal amila
schnitt sehen sondern sagen da schau her
da ist der märz das auch eine mit seiner
passion frisur ja so da gibt es auch mal
spannend aber gut jungen mann dazu
gedrängt werden könnte hätte ja auch
jetzt dazu gedrängt werden können das
ist jetzt nicht einfach wieder aufgibt
nach wenigen wochen das wird ja total
echt
klares ist dieses zukunftsteam
eigentlich man hat sich ja nicht getraut
zu sagen das ist ein schattenkabinett dh
die werden minister oder ministerin
werden oder irgendetwas anderes sondern
es war ja eigentlich wie so eine
entourage wo jeder nicht wusste also
auch der agenda setting danach fand ja
nicht statt nach dem motto so und jetzt
jeden tag ein von denen nach vorne
ziehen und den ganzen tag mit seinem
thema bespielen das heißt ich finde es
jetzt nicht so überraschend man lässt es
ihm könnten gar nicht die namen bekannt
und sich gegenseitig ich finde es aber
grundsätzlich richtig das ist das gab
ich hätte mir da nur auch andere köpfe
noch gewünscht so und die können ja
jetzt kommen aber ich glaube das
zukunftsteam ist jetzt gar nicht
überraschend für die menschen dass das
jetzt gerade besucher ist zukunft
vielleicht auch einer der dämlichsten
begriffe die sie in der politik übrigens
über alles nun also ihrer warum braucht
man überhaupt einen zukunft also stellt
ja niemanden vergangenheits team auf
oder und dass politik sich immer um das
kümmert was in der zukunft geschieht
also ich fand schon der name
zukunftsteam war an politischen bullshit
eigentlich kaum noch zu überbieten
besonders wenn man gesehen hat wie
angestrebt hat so ein team aufzustellen
man kann versagen werden zukunftsteam
aufstellt hat keine zukunft so ist
natürlich politik ohnehin ein geschäft
der konzentrierten anscheins erweckung
die zukunft kommt auch so also wir haben
es eigentlich selten erlebt in der
geschichte dass die zukunft nicht
gekommen ist weil wir uns nicht drum
gekümmert haben irgendwas passiert schon
das kann ja nicht gemeint sein gemeint
ist der anschein besonders modern zu
sein besonders innovativ zu sein und
irgendwie eine tolle zukunft zu
präsentieren die schöner ist als die
gegenwart meistens läuft es darauf
hinaus dass leute von gestern die das
heute nicht gebacken kriegen und
irgendwas von morgen erzählen das ist so
ein beliebtes ritual hilft aber
eigentlich nicht weiter bei aber den
handel person aber nicht der fall also
eine serie a steht für mich nicht für
vergangenheit soziales steht für mich
für die zukunft dass sylvia brandt steht
vor allen dingen für ihre frisur und
politischen lautlose scheint
der republik aber in einem wahlkreis in
dem wahlkreis gegangen aber das gibt uns
weiter da hätten ja auch diejenigen von
ihnen die anzahl der anfragen an silvia
brindisi abschlägig bescheiden wo sie
sich nicht raus sagt ist übersteigt bei
weitem was sie wollen aber sie spricht
eine sprache die die menschen verstehen
sie ist echt man hat das gefühl guck mal
die steht im leben die hat kinder die
weiß irgendwie was los ist davon fehlen
mir irgendwie in der politik ganz viele
also alle die uns corona aber olaf
scholz hat auch keine kinder angela
merkel hat auch keine kinder genau aber
so nicht kanzlerin werden aber ich finde
sie es weit mehr als ihre frisur und was
auch immer wieder die situation so ein
bisschen das du mir aber das ist jetzt
echt ein blödes niveau weiß total wieder
abstellt nur auf das aussehen und die
frisur völlig egal wie die frau aussieht
da sondern
dass man in einer sonst kein blödes die
doch nein das war eine konservative
partei nicht die frisur von friedrich
merz oder davon irgendwann
aber dass die unterstand hast du mich
frei ich komme hier sehr oft frisuren
von männern wie frauen wann immer sie
mir bemerkenswert erscheint und dass man
in einer konservativen partei wenn man
so auftritt mit einem speziellen hast du
dir nicht in das konservative bild herr
einpasst und sich so bewusst abheben
will dass man darüber noch mal kurz
sprechen darf das hat nichts mit übrigen
die wurzeln würden sondern das ist
einfach dass auch diese von der bea
reden war ja eigentlich auch das problem
ist mir aber weniger das outfit das
sondern das passt was war das problem
das problem ist dass man als partei vize
eine riesige chance hat im rampenlicht
zu stehen politische themen zu setzen
vor den gremiensitzungen sich zu wort zu
melden zu sagen wo es langgeht und all
das ist sehr sehr zurückhaltend das ist
ja ein sympathisches umfeld ist du
kommst da rein und du bist noch nicht
der wolfgang schäuble oder der bouffier
und die haben da ihre machtzentren
stehen hatten die gene chance für ihn
wer hat er jedes zukunftsteam hat mich
aus gegen die chance aber das ist nicht
aus meiner sicht also aus dem motorraum
sich genau sondern der des
establishments wie friedrich merz es
nennt wenn du da nichts neues reinlässt
dann wird auch nichts neues entstehen
oder nochmal die frage ist doch wirklich
was ist denn die aufgabe und ich finde
ich falsch zu sagen hatten die jene
chance weil ich finde die haben nicht
nur ihre chance gehabt sondern sie haben
sie auch zum teil auch genutzt wenn eine
lieb gewinnt irgendwie für eine klima
union steht und noch mal ganz ganz neue
themen da auch mit rein bringt dann
finde ich ist das genau ihre aufgabe und
dann hat sie die chance auch wie und ist
ein gutes stichwort die war auch hierbei
finden nach acht und die hat wirklich
der das gut genutzt die zeit das muss
man wirklich sagen die ist jetzt ein
festes gesicht wenn man auch wenn man
jetzt über das klima redet redet man
auch über sie und sie hat auch in also
ich kenne niemanden in deutschland über
das klima geredet und danach überhaupt
gewinnt das muss man doch mal ehrlich
sagen kein mensch
es gibt auch andere zeiten es muss also
ich eine cdu-politikerin ist ja gerade
auf jetzt also für die union ist sie
bislang die beste die es besetzt hat das
aber wirklich sagen ja union hat mit ihr
endlich mal auch vor dass verfügt die
union auf mein gesicht die sich ums
klima kümmern auf dem gesicht was
außerhalb der blase keiner kind ich will
ja auch niemand mit vielen freunden oder
seit wann 23 von allen talkshow gästen
unter 40 93 4
der chor ami das ist die mehrheit und
die gucken nicht talkshows aber es ist
ja wurscht ich wollte ja schon
verschiedentlich ansetzen um die leute
auch zum vorjahr zunehmen weil dieser
ganze wahlkampf ist so verkorkst und es
ist ein brummkreisel wahlkampf weil man
sich permanent die richtung wechseln
musste am anfang als er zum vorsitz
kandidierte hat armin laschet gesagt
manche meinen man müsse polarisieren ich
sage nein man muss zusammenführen was
hat er am schluss gemacht in seiner not
er hat auf die anderen drauf gedroschen
bis zum abwinken und auf die spd auf
olaf scholz die spd hat immer alles
falsch gemacht in historischen situation
man wo er hat ausdrücklich gesagt er
will kein schattenkabinett aufstellen
kein kompetenzteam was hat er gemacht
weil er merkt dass er überhaupt keine
schlagzeilen posierte er hat dann am
ende notgedrungen so ein team
aufgestellt also die armen leute sind
dort quasi verheizt worden weil man
merkte die ganze kampagne läuft nicht
das muss man ihnen zugute halten dafür
haben sie sich noch ganz wacker
geschlagen aber das problem war
eigentlich dass die union kein richtiges
konzept für die für die
wahlkampfkampagne hatte und dann auch
noch ein falsches weil sie tatsächlich
dachten mit irgendwelchen
nebulösen wort gefilden könnte man sehen
die in die regierung retten weil es mia
merkel vorher gemacht hat und dann kann
man darüber gleiten das hat nicht
funktioniert und dann musste man immer
hektischer am ende noch irgendwas zu
hinterziehen dazu gehört leider auch das
team einer der bemerkenswertesten spiels
übrigens der letzten tage fand ich peter
neumann der für innere sicherheit
zuständig war in dem zukunftsteam von
armin laschet
großartiger experte für terrorismus
großartig geschätzter experte auch immer
wieder hier bei bild.de peter falls du
siehst herzliche grüße der hat
getwittert naja wenn das mit der politik
nichts wird kann ich ja immer noch
lkw-fahrer in großbritannien werden weil
die ja gerade aus den tischen
daran sieht man das zukunftsteam hat mit
den politischen zu tun in zukunft ja
hatten versucht aber vermutlich nicht
unter dem kanzleramt
[Musik]